Trey,
my daddy Joe Rogan podcast by night all
day while we get that champion Joe Jose
Aldo.
That seems weird to me.
It doesn't make sense.
It seems weird to me.
And then Max Holloway interim champion,
like what is going on when you have a
champion who didn't win the title in a
fight in the,
in the octagon,
he was awarded it after he won an
interim title against Frankie Edgar,
which is a beautiful
performance on his part.
And then Max Holloway.
Where's an interim like who's within?
Think about how Max Holloway gotta I love
Max Holloway says nine fights in a row
that he won,
but then he beats Anthony Pettis who's
never fought at that weight for weight
once before cell phones Oliveira
but really not a top contender.
Really.
Not Realistically not.
And then leaves the weight class and was
at 55 and you won your belt off that.
You know,
it's so fucking strange.
It's weird how everyone has belts.
Well do you think that this is just a
part of the transition between [inaudible]
and WME and that is going to be like this
transitionary period where everything
about powerful watch,
Tyron Woodley Champs got
good taste in Washington.
Is there a Rolex?
It's a fat one,
whatever it is,
it looks good.
But the thing being like that bad boy,
it could be an Invicta,
but the thing is it's like,
do you,
do,
you know there's obviously some
sort of a transition going on.
80 people have been fired,
including Goldberg,
right?
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a crazy time.
So I think they're scrambling for stars
and I think belts brings along some sort
of ratings.
I just think they're in
this feeling out pair,
this transition period that they're,
they're just trying to figure it out.
And I think that's why Dana's entertaining
this Conor McGregor fight because
what else would we talk about?
Name some,
they named something else big going on
in the UFC right now what's interesting
is is does WME,
are they really,
or you know,
this organization,
have they really been involved in
anything where the outcome is totally
unpredictable?
Like combat sports because like
the promotion for the Holly,
uh,
or excuse me,
the Rhonda fight was a perfect
example of something like,
well we really hadn't
seen it that way before.
We're really hadn't seen it go
100% heavy towards the superstar.
Right?
Hundred percent heavy.
Usually it's like,
you know,
you would see a promo piece like say
if it's like Woodley versus Wonderboy,
you would see Wonderboy highlights,
you would see Woodley highlights,
you would see ass kicking on both sides.
You were like Holy Shit,
what a fight.
I can't wait.
They didn't do that at all.
They get is the way they would do a movie.
Yes,
they did it the way they
are promoted TV show,
they did it the way they promote a new
Kiefer Sutherland series on Netflix.
You know what I'm saying?
Only the star but,
but that shouldn't say Netflix,
I should say like Fox.
That's what scares me because Dana
white when it comes to this is a genius.
He would never,
I don't think you would
allow that to happen.
So I'm just wondering how involved he is.
Cause Without Dana.
If you just have WME running it,
fuck it.
Look dope though.
I'll tell you what,
I don't agree with the
fact that they ignore,
I'm a,
I'm a purist in a lot of ways
when it comes to combat sports.
And I think you have to respect
the hierarchy of the champion.
I don't give a fuck who
was the famous person.
This championship thing is so important.
When you have the,
if you're going to have champions,
you've got to respect the champion.
Like whoever the fuck it is.
It's,
it's super important to make a big deal
out of the fact that person's champion.
And they made like almost no deal out
of the fact that she was a champion.
It was this weird situation,
but it was really well done in
terms of like getting me amp,
does it?
Well,
I disagree.
I can see,
but for me it was for me.
Look,
I can get re you're the
one doing the fucking,
no,
no.
Most of that was not me.
Most of that was like you
open up the fucking curtain,
uh,
the,
the garage door and he
see her hitting the pads.
I had almost nothing in that.
The only thing that I said is,
I can't imagine she's not
going to come back and,
and be a,
you know,
what are motivated,
are pumped up or whatever.
By the way,
a lot of the stuff they
use in those promos.
Totally out of context.
Like when I was saying
that she's the best ever,
there's no one even close.
There's hurt.
And is everybody else was a long time ago.
That was a long time.
Correct.
I did not say that for this fight.
No,
it didn't say this for this place.
But you said that for the,
I think you said that for the batch go.
Hey,
a fight.
But yeah,
so see like when they're
making these promos,
patching stuff they're taking,
so for me,
I have a problem with that because
this is not what I would say.
Yeah.
So you're,
you're using like an old quote when she
was dominating people versus a new quote
post head kick,
knock out post the emergence of Amanda
Nunez after she stopped staring McMahon.
You verged is a,
you know what you're seeing
now in this division,
which is all this new blood coming up.
You're seeing this division percolate
and change and evolve and you're seeing
like higher level fighters come in
like Valentino Shift Chanko like Amanda
Nunez,
like Holly Home.
Like you're seeing all this
stuff take place in front of you.
Seeing this change in the women's division
the same way you saw a change in the
men's division from 97 to 2017 you're
seeing that now take place at an
accelerated pace and the
women in the women's division,
so who is dominant two years ago,
like to use a quote from two
years ago is really not fair.
I agree.
That's really not fair for them.
Kind of,
but,
but it builds the fight up,
right?
It builds the fight up but
it's not the way to do it.
No,
I agree.
I'm appears to.
But the thing is is if you understand
this sport and you look at,
let's say you want to copy the NFL,
the NFL would never just focus on Tom
Brady because there's a good fucking
chance Roethlisberger wins next week.
Now imagine if they just did
all promos on New England.
People were like,
what the fuck is this?
Exactly?
This is some bullshit fucking good man.
Worse than that,
what you're talking about,
all promos that aren't the champion.
Yeah.
Which is worse than that,
right?
Because you're talking about someone
who just lost by brutal knockout.
They're getting a shot
right away at the title.
And the idea is that
even though they lost,
they lost,
but it was some bullshit.
She's now,
she's best back now.
She's Bafta for 11 days.
She back fucking 411 it's
just a bad business plan.
There was a lot of talk
by people that don't know,
but I was listening to people talk
about it like I don't know who they are,
executive type people.
And I was like,
wow,
you guys have this idea of
how this is gonna go down.
Like they,
they,
they were just super,
super connected to this idea
and I don't know who they were.
I don't know if they're friends.
I don't know.
But there was a lot of people that we're
talking then had this idea that she was
just going to go in and storm
the castle and take back her.
I had a conversation with a high up exec
that a big time corporation and we're
talking to him and I'm like,
oh my,
you have no idea.
What did he say to you?
He,
he,
we were talking about Connor and Rhonda
and he was neither one e less than
mountain had that one hiccup.
She will never lose again
and like that's not true.
Lots is a good deals.
None of them no did.
She would never lose getting.
She goes and he goes
and Conner not a chance.
I'm like,
what are you talking about?
Two of these people
were talking backstage.
Gods are like skews me.
These people were talking about stage
and one of them didn't know Newton.
It's his name.
Yeah.
They were calling her cannon
fodder boy and I was like nine.
They don't know anything.
They could be,
I mean,
I don't know who they were.
Maybe they could be people who are friends
of people who know some people that
work at William Morris and they're
backstage dressed in fucking $2,000 suits,
so they look classy.
Who knows?
I don't know Willie Moore.
They shouldn't be doing anything
without going through Dana light first.
They should not be doing anything.
Yeah.
Been in the game way too long for you
guys to make any decisions without having
some sort of influence from a guy
who's come from the ground up from it.
You can't do that.
Listen,
our fan base is going to yell
bullshit on this man and if we,
if,
if Rhonda doesn't win,
we are going to get fucking rained.
Connor cannon fodder.
Huh?
Do you think?
Yeah.
That was the word that someone used.
Do you think that at this stage that
there should be some sort of clearly
established protocol as far as who
fight who and why you have to otherwise
you're no different than the WWE.
Right.
Then people won't take a lot of the
interim titles and the championship fights
serious.
Here's my argument against that.
Dan Henderson and Michael Bisping.
I wanted to see that fight.
It was goddamn touch.
Cause we love Dan.
I agree.
Love Dan and I love Mike and I love,
I know Mike wanted it back.
He finally got the title and he's like,
fuck this.
I know that guy knocked me out.
He's got his fucking picture
of him flying through the air.
Uh,
touching me in the head.
That's as long.
How cold the everybody
knows what that logo is.
Yeah.
He's like,
fuck him.
He landed it twice.
Then I'm in the fight.
No,
don't me wrong.
Matt might be fight of the year.
It's up there,
but I think you have to have some sort
of structure where people can see what's
going on.
It's just like,
maybe it's like a Usada
exemption exemption.
Brock Lesnar,
he got away with that for month.
I promise.
If you do that,
you're right.
You'll miss out on this really
fun kind of revenge pass.
Yes.
But then you can't say,
oh,
we want to be in the next NFL.
Let me ask you,
the NBA,
do you think,
I mean outside of like promote who see?
You see the thing is he can't deny.
It's weird.
It's like are you a sport
where someone has a very clear,
you know like the,
like the world series.
Like you can't,
like someone can't lose a game and then
all of a sudden be in the world series.
Right,
right.
It's just like there's a,
there's a protocol like you have
to go through that protocol,
but do you think that there's
a possibility you could
have something like that
some established set up but then they
could throw it to the Internet for like a
wildcard
cannot have that now and then maybe
the UFC gets three wild cards a year.
Oh God.
Oh my God.
Drama is the people who have
been answered in that thing.
But here's the other thing.
I wonder if an MNA young
Jamie shaking his head
for the all star teams and shit.
And then that's how y'all Ming is the
number one vote getter every year.
Why is it because Chinese
people is more of them?
Well,
technically yes,
but let me ask,
what does he do it online?
The Guy Right now,
that's the number one
forward for the warriors,
but like no one knows
even how to say his name.
Is he from China?
No,
his name is Josh shop with Trulia,
but he's gonna.
He's the leading vote getter.
Jeremy Lin to,
where's he from?
I have no idea.
Yeah,
I don't know.
Lithuanian maybe.
Let me ask you this question about it.
Here's a question.
Do you think,
I wonder about MMA,
whether being champion in most of the
divisions is even that important to the
fans?
In other words,
what's important to
people is Conor Mcgregor,
right?
Rhonda Rousey,
the people that have the co,
there's something colorful about them.
Complicated people.
Somebody who speaks well.
So we,
we watched those guys,
but I'm not so sure that because
Michael Bisbing is champion,
that his viewership goes up as your mom,
clinically proven that championship fight.
Terrible,
terrible point.
And you know what?
I need you to take a break after that.
But to your point,
you can say Rhonda was the bigger stuff,
but Ronald was a different force
and the reason she got so big as,
because she was champions
Rondo's never champion.
We're not even,
but also like what she was just,
she was winning and losing one.
It doesn't matter what she did to indulge
that whole popularity thing was very
different than Connor's approach of
Connor decided to take that exact same
approach and go do a ton of movies and
go do a ton of talk shows and go do a ton
of,
do one commercial Budweisers and
entourage and all this different shit.
If he started doing that same shit,
his star would rise proportionally to
weigh her star rose and his performances
inside the octagon was suffer
right proportionately to wear.
Hers did and he didn't do
it and he's still bigger.
We were talking about that
guy that did that interview.
He's a sports guy and
he was talking about,
no,
no.
The other guy,
the black guy who was with him,
is that his name?
And he had a great point.
Shannon Sharpe had a
great point and he said,
Rhonda cheated on MMA.
He said,
you gotta be all in and says you can't
go and do a bunch of other shit and think
you're just so much better than everybody
else that it's never going to catch
up.
He comes from another 1% or athlete knows
exactly how all this kind of tempting
shall Shannon Sharpe stuck
to the game to set it.
When he said it,
I was like,
this guy's dead.
Right.
I think this business model though,
the only problem with the business model
is that with MMA it's really hard to
invest in the champion because
of the nature of the sport.
The the belt.
We'll chant like especially when
you're investing for one fights,
right?
But still you're,
but you're investing because all the time,
but you're not investing
for in the champion.
You're investing in the organization
and the fact that they have the best
fighters in the world.
What you're doing with each
fight is promoting a fight.
What I'm saying is that you have to
respect the hierarchy of the championship.
Above all,
the champion is the champion.
And if you don't respect the hierarchy
of the champion of your somehow or
another saying that this champion ain't
shit unless this champion is fighting
Mike fucking Tyson when Tyson was 20
years old and just smashed and everybody
and you knew all my God,
this is going to be the youngest
ever heavyweight champion,
then you focus on that guy with the
same amount of fervor that it demands.
Right.
But that's not the case here.
You know,
you're talking about an insanely like in
that particular Ronda Rousey fight and
insanely dangerous champion.
Yeah.
Who just smashed me,
said Tate and,
and you're talking about an x factor.
We were like,
we really don't know what we're going
to kit exactly with Ron bess and put all
the money in the,
yeah,
right.
So you've got,
you've got,
but also you have an
insanely marketable champion.
First of all,
the first ever openly gay
women's MMA champion and man's l.
It should be never been an
openly gay MMA champion.
Right.
So you have the whole Lgbtq,
whatever they are now a is
username as about APA plot.
People that,
but you have also a bunch of people that
respect that in a progressive people
that say,
hey,
this is great.
Like look,
it shows how diverse the UFC is.
Sure.
He's amazing.
Yeah,
and the stupid shit that Meryl
Streep said the other day,
like one of the reasons why she probably
said it is because she's seeing Ronda
Rousey's face plastered
all over the place.
The face,
the place and she's saying,
Hey,
you know you take women of
foreigners out of Hollywood,
you're going to be left
with football and MMA.
She doesn't understand the full MMA like
you saw tonight was Gil Rodriguez is
80% foreigners.
It's so wrong about that.
And that's also art.
That's that jumping,
spinning back kick would be art.
Oh come on that you tell me
that three 60 round kick.
Just fucking dance but harder cheese.
You got to hit somebody with it.
Yes.
It's,
it's just like rhythmic gymnastics.
She just doesn't know
what she's on educated.
I mean if dance is an art than gymnastics
in competition is also an art because
it's very similar.
It's just under more pressure.
Right.
So of gymnastics is an art.
How the fuck is how our
three 60 round kicks?
Not,
oh shit.
Oh,
that guy on the ground is,
it was a bad motherfucker.
Hey,
it's weird.
She used her lifetime achievement award
to talk shit about MMA and football.
I think she was making
a clumsy larger point,
but yes,
for sure.
Celebrate what you,
oh,
it was Nina and saw the crime.
No,
and he didn't start off one whoa.
Rear naked around three.
That's a Amanda Nunez girlfriend hollow.
Okay.